ma vie s'arrêtera à 42 ans ma vie de
danseuse s'arrêtera à 42 ans
en tout cas c'est l'ordre établi à
l'opéra de paris
les danseurs sont bien la retraite à cet
âge là pourquoi 42 parce qu'en fait la
règle a changé avant c'était 45 pour les
hommes mais 40 pour les femmes
du coup on a coupé la poire en deux
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire tout simplement qu'à 42 ans je ne
pourrai plus danser ni à l'opéra ni
ailleurs parce qu'aucune autre compagnie
s'engage une danseuse de cet âge là une
danseuse qui aurait encore moins souple
moins endurants moins tonique usées en
quelque sorte
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui mon corps est
moins performant mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que mon jeu est plus abouti j'ai
gagné en maturité artistique
j'ai plus d'expérience tous les rôles
que j'ai interprétés
et puis ma vie tout simplement notamment
le fait d'être maman depuis peu m'ont
beaucoup apporté et c'est ce que je les
livre en scène mon jeu aujourd'hui en
tant que soliste n'a plus rien à voir
avec celui que j'avais à 16 ans lorsque
j'ai débuté dans corps de ballet ça fait
maintenant 27 ans que chaque jour je me
consacre à la danse
d'abord comme élève et ensuite comme
professionnel depuis l'âge de 10 ans je
suis en justaucorps et collants face à
un miroir
j'essaye de rendre mon corps gracieux
je répète des gestes des dizaines et des
dizaines de fois pour les rendre
harmonieux
beau à regarder aussi naturel que le
fait de respirer tout en masquant les
forts parce que c'est ce qui différencie
la danse classique des autres sports de
haut niveau on doit masquer l'effort et
la difficulté nos mouvements doivent
être fluides sans heurts ils doivent
paraître réalisable par tous alors que
c'est un travail assidu permanent de
chaque jour et surtout malheureusement
jamais acquis et sourire alors que
parfois on a mal en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que pour être danseur il faut
vraiment aimé l'effort le masque est
certes mais il faut aimer se dépasser et
sa gelée compris très tôt à 10 ans
lorsque je suis arrivé à l'école à paris
ça faisait à peu près deux ans que je
faisais de la danse comme ça en amateur
juste pour le plaisir
comme beaucoup de petite fille j'étais
fasciné par le tutu la préparation du
spectacle de fin d'année et tout le
forez qui va avec
mais quand j'ai quitté mon pays basque
natal que j'ai débarqué à paris à
l'école de danse de l'opéra en internat
là les choses sérieuses ont commencé et
du spectacle de fin d'année
on est passé au concours de fin d'année
à vrai dire c'était même un peu le
concours toute l'année parce que très
tôt on nous a mis en compétition et on
me l'a beaucoup reproché j'étais pas
assez compétitive un jour une maman
professeur qui a dit à ma mère votre
fille
il faut qu'elle devrait il faudrait
qu'elle devienne plus méchante sinon
elle va se faire bouffer pas facile
d'entendre ça j'étais pas préparé
je n'étais pas préparée à débarquer dans
ce monde là si jeune
un monde dont on parle aux enfants comme
des adultes on ne parle que de rigueur
et discipline
j'ai été éloigné de mon cocon familial
si rassurant si chaleureux j'ai été
éloigné de mon petit frère avec qui je
me dispute et temps mais ça aussi
c'était plutôt rassurant
j'ai trouvé que ce nom de la manquer
d'empathie mais pour autant malgré tout
ça et moi j'aimais vraiment danser
la première fois que je suis montée sur
la scène de l'opéra garnier j'avais 11
ans c'était pour ce qu'on appelle les
démonstrations qui ont lieu chaque année
c'est en fait un cours de danse à ces
condensés qu'on met en scène ça dure à
peu près une dizaine de minutes pour les
plus jeunes
j'avais la trouille au ventre mais
j'étais bien j'ai compris que c'est là
où je voulais être sur scène et depuis
sur la jeunesse et c'est d'attendre y
retourner alors après de longues années
de travail de joie de doutes et de
remises en question aujourd'hui j'ai
réalisé mon rêve je fais partie de la
troupe de l'opéra
je suis soliste je vis de ma passion je
suis d'une nature réservée mais c'est
vrai que la danse permet de
m'extérioriser et de me surprendre aussi
parfois je peux aimer passionnément être
odieuse devenir folle mourir de chagrin
être une jeune fille innocente une
prostituée ou une femme fatale c'est ça
mon métier je lui en scène raconter des
histoires par l'expression de mon corps
la trouille au ventre que j'avais à 11
ans elle est toujours là elle est bien
présente à chaque représentation
mais aujourd'hui ça va mieux c'est mon
allié je les apprivoiser la rigueur fait
partie de mon métier elle fait partie du
travail
mais une fois en scène là c'est tout
autre chose
c'est un moment de partage et de don de
soi
en tout cas c'est ma façon d'appréhender
chaque spectacle
alors si tout ça s'arrête à 42 ans
et bah ça veut dire que dans cinq ans on
va m'enlever mon moyen d'expression
tout ça va s'arrêter du jour au
lendemain cinq ans ça peut paraître long
on peut se dire que j'ai le temps
mais le compte à rebours a déjà commencé
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait oui je
pourrais rester dans le milieu de la
danse je pourrais devenir professeur
chorégraphe ou répétitrice sauf que pour
l'instant j'en ai pas envie
je suis une interprète c'est ma façon de
vivre la danse c'est comme si j'allais
dire à céline dion qui aurait la voix
qui chevrote apte à plus de voix c'est
pas grave tu peux écrire des chansons
non c'est pas aussi simple que ça alors
dans cinq ans il va falloir du
rebondissent et je vais pas décider
maintenant
après tout il n'y a pas d'urgence
j'ai besoin que mes envies mûrissent
j'ai pas envie de choisir par dépit dans
la précipitation
je pense qu'on peut pas arrêter un
métier de passion tel que celui là comme
ça d'un claquement de doigts je vais pas
arrêter de danser un vendredi pour
reprendre une autre activité le lundi
non je crois que je vais avoir besoin
d'un peu de temps pour me poser pour
pouvoir prendre un nouveau départ
mais en attendant en attendant
j'aimerais vivre ces cinq prochaines
années vraiment pleinement intensément
comme ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à présent
sur ça je les vends mon directeur pour
me positionner
je lui ai parlé des rôles vers lesquels
je tends qu'est ce que j'aimerais
interpréter dans quelle direction je
voudrais aller revendiquer son savoir
faire et sa maturité artistique essayer
de ne pas céder face au jeunisme et puis
nous refuser aucune rencontre même
celles qui paraissent un peu effrayante
celles qui peuvent mettre un peu en
danger comme aujourd'hui j'ai accepté de
faire ce toc
c'est une démarche tellement éloigné de
moi la scène je connais c'est un endroit
familier
suit bien le public je connais il ne
m'effraie pas mais de moi d'habitude ça
accompagné de musique je porte un
costume je ne suis pas bien muriel je ne
suis pas restreinte à rester dans un
périmètre aussi serré moi j'utilise
toute la scène je saute je tourne et
puis surtout surtout je suis muette
alors finalement elle m'a finalement
peut-être que je vous un peu menti
peut-être que je me mens aussi un peu à
moi même quand je dis que j'aurais le
temps je verrai ça plus tard peut-être
que je suis déjà en train de préparer la
presse peut-être que ma présence ici
n'est pas si anodine
on